good morning Hank it's Tuesday quick
disclaimer do not try this at home so I
woke up around 8:30 in downtown LA to
meet publicist extraordinaire elise
marshall and best-selling author slash
old pal ransom riggs who took us to the
building where they filmed part of Blade
Runner which featured a Carbonite in
case Charlie Chaplin and then we went to
an extremely creepy long abandoned
Hospital now sometimes used as a setting
for horror movies this is the kind of
place ransom takes his friends which
won't surprise you if you've read his
novel miss Peregrine's Home for peculiar
children we visited the eerie Chapel
which reminded me of my Chaplin days a
kitchen where patients meals were cooked
don't don't don't don't don't don't
oldest coffee don't tell me what's in
there don't tell me what's in there no
amazing Catholic mr. wizard big Bill Nye
all right well I'm gonna let the camera
book but I'm not gonna look myself get a
little closer yeah there you go
and there was an endless string of
hospital rooms caked with mildew and
bird dung so many of the windows were
blown out that it was hard to say for
sure whether the place was inside or
outside and I could hear bird singing
and rodents scurrying in the ceilings
like many abandoned buildings there was
evidence of recent squatters poorly
spelled graffiti nasty nasty water
fountains but what struck me most with
the skeletal remains of dozens of
hospital beds and then we made our way
down to the basement
finding the morgue by this time even
ransom who is hard to scare was getting
pretty creeped out ha ha ha ha I am
course I'm very easy to scare Hank in an
operating room much of the equipment
still there miraculously unlooted I saw
a figure in the mirror oh my god and
about peed myself before realizing it
was me we then found our way to the
records room full of EKGs of hearts that
had stopped beating decades ago finally
we made our way to the boiler room the
beautiful dead guts of the hospital Hank
abandoned buildings scare the crap out
of me but I love tunnels steam tunnels
storm drains sewers whatever but the
sewer entrance looked a smidge
unappealing so instead we fumbled around
until we found a steam tunnel
yeah we're well underground now as we
continued it got colder the walls
narrowed can you give me the light I
said end it's hard to tell
watch I brought my police flashlight
alright I'm gonna go okay that tunnel
led to a flooded room and then to
another tunnel and then to a huge room
entirely empty except for this bloody
bathtub horror movie left over I hope by
that I'd had enough and as we made our
way up and out of the hospital's bowels
I found myself wondering what the hell I
was doing it's true that such spaces
remind us in a scary but seductive way
of our own temporariness and the
relatively short life of all that we
build and do and it's true that the
abject darkness of the tunnels made the
world outside impossibly bright and
alive but this is also true it is nice
on a Thursday morning in April to be a
kid for a while exploring with old
friends never knowing what wonder or
terror may await around the corner and
isn't that why we explore and also why
we read and watch sports and browse
tumblr and study astrophysics whether
we're watching horror movies or
accidentally visiting their sets
I think we're after the terrifying
awesome otherworldly feeling of not
knowing what lies in wait Hank I'll see
you on Friday